hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com
so as usual i'm here to make some
technical analysis and
show you all the different tools and
techniques that i like to use at work
to make money on the markets and most
importantly i'm here to show you how to
do it yourself
so today i'm here to make a big big big
update guys on amc
so let's get into it
[Music]
and guys so as usual we start on the
fourth time frame and
let's see what the chart of amc is
telling us
so we had a pretty impressive start of
the week
i told you guys that we are in the third
wave that we're gonna see
those very strong moves up uh arriving
very soon
and we did we did we had since the
beginning of the week
amc closed at 12 when i did my last
video guys and i was telling you that
the 15th level
will be taken this week and it
is now taken back for good i think
so we took around 40 guys 40
in a matter of two days i'm here taking
into account the aftermarket i think amc
was slightly lower like 16.4
on if i take the daily the official
closing level is 16.4
but in after hours we went
to 17. why 17 guys because
you can see here that's why trend lines
for me is
the you know it's my major tool that's
why you can see on my charts
all those lines everywhere there are
basically some levels where i had
consolidation
or we had a maximum or a minimum level
here 17 guys it's uh the highest level
we had
in the move down that started at 25 all
right
we dipped down here came back here so it
was long time ago guys but the market
remembers
so now what is interesting to notice
is first that this third wave
to me might be complete or maybe not
we're gonna zoom in
i'm gonna do this very soon so we're
gonna have more information all right
i'm gonna apply the same method actually
applied here
i told you guys that after this breakout
occurred
uh i was here very bullish i told you
that
this was a first wave then the second
wave corrected
a bit more than expected uh for those
who have watched my previous video
i was telling you you know maybe that
this you know this kind of
consolidation here was for me a bit uh
too long in time
but fair enough it's still valid and
then we started our third wave and when
the volume here
arrived yes and we took back first
the 12th level this was for me the
confirmation that we were actually
in this third wave i'm talking about
this
blue five wave development so
from then i knew that in my third wave
we are going to have
five waves as well because guys this is
the principle of
elliot wave theory that is basically
telling you that
moves up develop in five waves one two
three four five and move them
develop in three ways a b c for those
who want to know more about the idiotic
theory just click on the link
in the description of this video and
you're gonna receive a free video where
i explain
everything guys about all these
different patterns and how to
use them so here the information i had
the last time i did my video
is that we are in the third wave and
that
in the third wave this is the beauty of
illiot you can apply it you know you can
zoom in and apply it again
zoom in apply it again and we're going
to do this very soon for now we're on
the four hours time frame
and here we had one two three four and i
told you guys the fourth wave
to me it makes sense that the 12 level
would hold but even if i had
some more move down as long as we were
staying above the
maximum of wave one we don't enter wave
one
territory so we don't have a diagonal we
having a typical impulse
and this is exactly what we had and now
we are doing the fifth wave
all right so we are inside the fifth
wave of
this five wave development inside my
third wave and the question we're having
is where is this fifth wave gonna go so
to answer that question
let's zoom in and let's see if i'm
having five waves inside it
this is gonna give us some very good
hints and
for now what i'm seeing guys in this
fifth wave
you see sometimes even the hourly time
frame is a bit
too long let me zoom in on the 30
minutes time frame and analyze a bit
what's
happening here so
it's a rough guess because here i'm not
sure i have a one two or not but let's
say this is a one this is a two
this is only a three guys because one
two three
four five all right so this is the third
wave
so i'm expecting some kind of a
correction inside this
wave and maybe four and five all right
so let's see
we need to know what will happen here we
have different scenarios all right
so let me here give you the different
scenarios and what they would mean
so the first scenario is that this fifth
wave is not complete yet
and that we are going to take not only
the 15 level
back but the 17 level back as well
this would be a very very very good sign
we have already
a lot of good signs guys so we don't
actually need this one
but if we have it it's kind of the last
the very last one
look i told you guys that third waves
they usually take back some important
levels
and here we started with taking back the
12 level
right it was the maximum that we had
here so it's an important level on the
short term
we took it back in the third wave of
this third wave
then we went to the 15 level got
rejected fine
no problem we gathered some strengths we
took some liquidity sitting here you
know a lot of buyers were actually
waiting at a 12 level
and they were right and they both
massively amc on monday morning session
and they pushed the price through the 15
level
like very strongly let's see i'm pretty
sure we had
some reactions here so if i go into five
minutes time frame
let's see how things actually occurred
at the 15 level you see
so we have this so inside the third of
the third of the third guys all right
so the most impulsive period we had
which last you know between 5 30
you know between those four hours guys
so you know it's the most impulsive
period of this whole development for now
we still got rejected at the 15 level
all right
we got rejected here exactly 14.6
and then we moved higher and we went to
the 17 level
very impulsively so this looks very good
to me
let's go back on hourly timeframe
and now like i said we have a few
scenarios here so either
we take back this level and this will be
the end
of this third wave that would be here
like this
and we would have the one two three four
five inside the fifth wave
just like we did inside the third wave
then we would probably correct
so that's why it's important to know
where we are going all right
if we are going like for example i don't
know to the 20 level it's possible guys
amc is on fire
you know like i said last week but even
more right now
so everything can happen i'm gonna show
you very soon the short interest data
the call
option data as well uh the open interest
and you're gonna see guys that have some
interesting information
on this data as well so if we go
you know much higher around the 20 level
this would be very good
for the false wave collection because we
are going to have a false wave all right
it's going to come soon so i'm not sure
it's going to come this week or early
next week so maybe we're going to push
higher the whole week
maybe we're just going to consolidate
around the 17 area
it's very hard to say and it's not that
important guys what is important
is to know where this force wave is
going to correct
so if we go around 20 maybe we're only
going to correct for the 17 level
but most likely we're going to come back
to retest the 15 level
you know maybe very quickly but we're
going to probably retested it
because you know on the fourth time
frame we took it all right
it's confirmed it's very clean one two
candles
consecutive candles above this level and
usually guys usually
like ninety percent of the time after we
take back some match levels like this
they are retested so for those who want
to buy amc
15 like exactly 14.7
so let's call it 15 guys because you
never know sometimes we don't touch it
perfectly is the right level to do so so
my bullish case is we break 17 then we
retest only 17 before going higher
my a bit less bullish scenario is that
we break 17
and will be test 15 and my kind of
bearish case
is that we get rejected right away to at
17
and we we test either 15 which is the
same or
we even retest the 12 level
is that possible guys it's not
technically really possible it's not
really possible we go to 12
because this would make my new blue
five-wave development here
a diagonal all right a diagonal is when
wave
four enters wave one territory so maybe
we're gonna retest it but for sure we're
not gonna go through this
if we do this means that all i'm saying
here is wrong
which definitely is not when you have a
look
at everything that we said third waves
are very impulsive
and with high volumes and take back some
mental levels this is exactly what we're
having
so i'm very convinced that this is a
third wave
and it's the third wave of the third
wave the blue
wave here guys is nothing else than the
third wave itself
so it's uh one
two and this is a three so then we're
gonna have four and five let's see
okay so i'm gonna keep this for another
video where
i'm gonna do some more long-term
analysis with you guys all right but
my blue wave is the third wave itself so
it can't actually correct to 12 below 12
it's impossible otherwise everything is
wrong like i said which
you know may happen you know but i
really don't believe it
so my preferred scenario
guys is that we hover around the 17
level maybe slightly above maybe
slightly below
but ultimately we're gonna correct guys
so don't panic if you see the price
action dropping it is
completely normal just like we had here
in those in this false wave and i told
you that amc deep is nothing
and i'm going to do another video if we
drop even by 20
where i'm gonna tell you the same thing
it is completely normal it is expected
so let's see let's see if we break this
17 level or not
but anyways guys this is what will
probably play out
at the end of this week and at the early
beginning of next week
now let's go to the financial data
together so i want to show you
all the option data as i like to do
so now amc guys is at 17 all right so it
was at 12 before
so before we had around five percent
synthetic short interest
now we are at 17 so we have some gamma
here
we go from five to seven percent so we
have 500 million usd
synthetic short exposure on the option
market
mostly coming guys so this is you know
here are the strikes
and like i showed you guys in many of my
video you know
i compute myself the delta for each of
these options
you know i use this formula here uh i
use the volatility that i have here
and i use the option open interest that
i get
from yahoo finance so i compute all this
data and i'm able to know what is the
synthetic short on amc
and where it's coming from so here in
red it's my synthetic shot so it's
mostly coming from the 10 strike the 10
strike hole
but also from the 40 strike call guys
and we had 17 million shares last
sunday we're having now almost 20
million shares so people keep buying
this
the volatility here was at 270 and 175
it dropped a little bit so i'm not sure
why it's dropping
you know it's not what i was expecting
here but it's still very high guys you
know dropping from
you know 270 to 260 is no big deal
and we're still having this very bullish
kind of
data on this option market now if i want
to have a look
guys at the regular short interest we're
having from the date of
the 14th of may that just got released
you know so this is finra reports so of
course they're not including all the
naked shots
i'm not sure how many of those are but
i'm gonna
keep an eye on this data that is updated
regularly
and that is giving us good signals so
here we're having a more short interest
interesting guys you know so you need
amc to go higher
before the hedge funds you know increase
their shorts position
and before you can really have a short
squeeze for now guys this is we are far
from a short squeeze
you know we having a very bullish
development that will keep
happening for me but this is not a short
squeeze because to me the shots are not
big enough
but once again maybe there are enough
naked shots two short squeeze
but we don't need a short squeeze prime
c to go higher we just need this
price action to keep developing like it
is so if i add
to this short interest which is 21 of
the total shelf load
the seven percent that i have here on my
option market guys
this seven percent here then i come up
with a total 28
of short interest on amc so guys you
know even
if we don't take into account the naked
shots this is still
a lot and if i take the then i can
compute
the uh dtc so monthly and weekly
using the volumes so the weekly volume
is very high so the dtc is actually
quite low
you know only 1.3 but on the monthly the
monthly volume are a bit lower so we are
close to two so once again
for the shorts to be bought back in
panic by hedge funds we need to be
around the three
five area so we are not there yet but
it's getting
hot so yeah guys that's it for me i hope
you enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys